[Musica]
Ognuno di noi ha una storia ma prima di
raccontarvi la mia Voglio chiedervi se
la vostra vita fosse un film In che
categoria sarebbe catalogata comico Noir
drammatico romantico io Di una cosa sono
certa la mia vita voglio che sia
catalogata nel genere comico ero piccola
ero piccola come tutti quanti noi ero
scalmanata mi piaceva fare 10 cose G
devo sempre avevo voglia di prendermi in
giro prendeva in giro Diciamo che ho
preso in giro pure mio padre con la
scuola perché a scuola non andavo
benissimo lì mio padre non era tanto
contento ero piccola Quando giocavo al
poliziotto e al ladro Io ovviamente era
il poliziotto stavo sulla sedia di legno
di casa di mia nonna sul in cucina e
correvo contro contro mia cugina e mi ci
buttavo sopra molte volte l'ho fatta
male la vedevo soffrire ma soffriva in
silenzio quindi ero sicura da bambina
che da grande volevo fare il poliziotto
né n né la ballerina né la cantante e
soprattutto né l'attrice perché non ne
sono capace eh nel avevo 15 anni quando
arrivarono per la prima volta I Vespri
Siciliani al mio paese Gela arrivarono i
primi che arrivarono furono i
bersaglieri e mi sono subito innamorata
di loro Mi sono innamorata tantissimo
della loro divisa della mimetica e mi
sono innamorata tantissimo anche del
loro tipico caratteristico copricapo il
fetz quel copricapo rosso col pompon blu
mi sono pure innamorata di uno di loro
ma l'amore con lui durò due mesi il
tempo che si fece la missione in Italia
in Sicilia ma e poi e poi finì ma in
realtà il mio amore per lui finì pure
pure per me finì presto ma non l'amore
per la divisa ero piccola avevo 15 anni
quando cominciai a a pensare che volevo
fare il militare ma e pensavo ogni
giorno Chissà Sem mai le donne potevano
far parte dell'esercito fin quando nel
2000 anno in cui mi sono diplomata
entrano le prime donne dell'esercito che
se mio padre che volevo fare la
domandina mio padre mi disse Guarda
Monica Lascia stare tu 100 ne vuoi fare
e poi non ne concludi neanche una quindi
fai Fai una cosa prima scriviti
all'università e mi raccomando non farmi
ridere come tutte le altre scuole prima
e poi magari se persiste la tua volontà
lo lo Potrai pure fare in realtà non mi
sono neanche mai laureata So solamente
che al veso anno non compiuto anno in
cui potevo ancora fare domandina per
entrare a fare il volontario Ho
presentato la domandina e da lì a poco
sono entrata nell'esercito le amiche mie
erano incredule diciano impossibile tu
sovv che trasgredisce le leggi che se ti
dicono di fare una cosa fai l'estremo
apposto impossibile tu durerai lì Un
giorno io dicio no è impossibile Quello
è il mio sogno perché avevo dell'idea
dell'esercito che fosse come i tipici
film americani io io ero convinta di
andare a fare Soldato Jane ero già
pronta tipo ad alzarmi la notte se
buttata a terra dalla brandina e buttata
fuori Durando una grandinata per per per
fare tipo addestramento oppure di essere
chiamata con i peggio nomi Come si
vedono nei film tipo F Jacket che ci
palla il sergente che lo chiama alla
pala lardo al al al commilitone in
realtà tipo l'esercito non era così non
è così fortunatamente soprattutto e e
però io mi ero proprio innamorata tanto
che quando mia mamma è venuta a vedermi
a fare il il giuramento mi disse Monica
Io finalmente ti vedo realizzata non
t'ho mai visto mai così contenta in
tutta la mia vita Infatti era così nel
2007 sono stata assegnata al primo
Reggimento bersaglieri e finalmente
facevo il militare operativo mio sogno
si era avverato lì con i bersaglieri ho
fatto un sacco di di operazioni sia in
Italia che all'estero in Italia ha fatto
strade sicure Strade Pulite G8 poi sono
partita per la prima volta in
Afghanistan tra 2009 e il 2010 E lì mi
sono innamorata di quel posto un posto
bellissimo Sì desertico però dove la
gente ti ti regalava tantissime emozioni
e per quando si dice se ne parli male
perché c'è un sacco di gente brutta in
realtà gran parte tipo la maggior parte
sono gente tipo buona che ci hanno molte
volte salvato la vita e e mi sono resa
conto che con poco si poteva far
contenta tipo una persona poi in realtà
tipo lo sceneggiatore della della mia
storia ha pensato perché rendere la vita
così semplice a questa ragazza perché
tipo non farle fare un'altra missione e
magari stravolgerle la vita E così è
stato Sono partita nel 2012 per un'altra
missione in Afghanistan e premetto che
prima di partire mi sentivo qualcosa di
strano sono andata da una mia amica
ovviamente con la mia simpatia e le
dissi Ma guarda Patrizia sono sicura che
stavolta tipo Muoio se dovessi morire se
dovessi avverarsi questa cosa che io
penso Mi raccomando non voglio le queste
persone non le voglio al mio funerale
che lei mi disse Ma Monica ma stai
sempre a prenderci a cazzeggiare stai
sempre a prendermi in giro parla Pensa
pensa le cose serie dice guarda più
seria di così io penso che mi succeda
qualcosa e se dovesse succedere Mi
raccomando ste persone ovviamente lo
sceneggiatore è stato buono perché sono
ancora qua sono ancora qua con voi e
quindi posso ancora aggiornare la mia
lista delle persone che non voglio il
mio funerale e comunque succede che il
24 Marzo 2012 del ero di qrf si chiama
Quick Reaction Force è una specie di
primo intervento Succede qualcosa se è
prima dovuto intervenire quel giorno
c'hanno lanciato delle bombe da mortaio
dentro la base una di queste ovviamente
fortunatamente ha preso me la mia
premonizione si era avverata e però lo
sceneggiatore è stato sempre tipo Corino
con me nei miei confronti Sì ok va bene
Tipo la tragedia mi fino a un certo
punto rendiamola un po' comica e io mi
sono sentita come in un in un videogioco
come Call of Duty no ti arriva la
ventata d'aria calda e ti vedi tutto
grigio e la prima cosa Istintivamente
senza sentire dolore vedi cosa ti è
successo mi ero vista un po' la mano
aperta del del sangue che mi usciva
sotto la cintura e il mio amico che
m'aveva visto che ero in mezzo al
piazzale mi è venuto a prendere m'ha
tirato sotto l'anima dandomi i primi
soccorsi tutti pensano che la gamba
l'abbia persa che mi sia saltata in
realtà non è così perché lo
sceneggiatore vi ho detto è stato una
persona precisa facciamo che facciamo la
scheggio prend l'arteria femorale me la
cauterizza fortunatamente quindi il
circolo su ce l'avevo quindi rimaneva in
vita ma in realtà la gamba se andata per
il fatto che non arrivava il sangue
quindi necrosi Però anche non c'era solo
quello c'era il fatto che un'altra
Scheggia aveva preso invece l'intestino
e 50 50 cm di intestino sono andati via
da lì Comunque m'hanno trasferito a
Ramstein in Germania dove dopo essermi
svegliata m'hanno detto quello che mi
era success quello che non avevo più
Sono andata al Celio e lì vi dico
solamente che al Celio girava in giro
tipo con la carrozzina e una Trombetta
delle dei bambini mi facevo tutte le mi
faceva tutto il corridoio così tanto che
ogni tantoo un un maresciallo si
arrabbiava e mi diceva Monica Questo è
un ospedale la gente soffre non puoi
fare tutto sto gran casino dicevo Guarda
se se non se non lo faccio qua do devo
portare l'allegria dove già c'è
impossibile ma eh Mentre tipo io stavo
in Afghanistan stavo in gulistan la
seconda volta si chiama Valle delle rose
ma di di di Fiorito non c'è nulla è
tutto deserto non c'è vita però posso
dire che grazie al gulistan la gulistan
M ha ridato la vita perché stavo stavo
su sul letto d'ospedale quando de
correvano le paralim di di Londra 2012
facevo zapping ero con una mia amica e
ho conosciuto quella che sarebbe
diventata poi la la la la mia gara e
vidi per la prima volta correre anche
Martina Cironi la prima italiana che
prendeva l'oro a quelle Paralimpiadi e
un po' per me un po' per la mia famiglia
dissi la mia amica soprattutto un po'
per sfida contro me stessa perché mi
mancava la gamba e qualcosa con la gamba
che mi mancava dovevo fare dissi la mia
amica va bene io appena posso voglio una
protesi da da corsa e voglio voglio
correre e Voglio battere Martina alle
prossime Paralimpiadi II le Paralimpiadi
successivi sono andata sono arrivata
prima Eh sì magari sono arrivata terza
ma vicino a me comunque ci stava Martina
Ceroni in parte il mio sogno si era
avverato ero sono riuscita a far della
mia vita quello che volevo ancora non
l'ho battuta eh non sui 100 sui 60 l'ho
già battuta successivamente e e sono
sono ri andata alle Paralimpiadi di
Tokio 2021 la grande paralimpiade dopo
il grande putiferio della della pandemia
e il sogno il sogno singolo diventava
anche sogno collettivo perché sul podio
non eravamo più in due ma eravamo in tre
al primo posto ci stava la fantastica
Ambra Sabbatini al secondo era scesa di
un gradino Martina cheroni perché capita
al terzo ci sono sempre stata io quindi
spero di esserci così anche anche un po'
più a lungo e abbiamo Abbiamo dipinto
dipinto il cielo del dello stadio di
Tokyo pioveva però l'abbiamo dipinto
tutto da azzurro è stata l'emozione più
grande della mia vita no perché le altre
non lo siano state perché era condivisa
eravamo una squadra non era non stavo
vincendo sono io ma St stavamo vincendo
tutte e tre soprattutto stava vincendo
l'atletica paralimpica
e in quella medaglia Infatti ci sta la
bambina che giocava a fare il poliziotto
ci sta la Il Bersagliere e soprattutto
ci sta quell' eterna cazzona che vede
sempre il bicchiere mezzo pieno e mai
mezzo vuoto è un altro esempio posso
farlo dicendo che quest'anno ho fatto i
mondiali stavo perché lo sceneggiatore
sempre non è mai stato tipo tenue nelle
mie anche nelle mie relazioni amorose
stavo in una fase distruttiva con mio ex
compagno e e niente Sono arrivata all
alla gara che ero distrutta e comunque
anche lì Mi sono rimboccata le maniche e
ho deciso io cosa farne della mia vita e
sono anch'io anche là siamo arrivate
prima seconda e terza Io ovviamente
terza ed è stato ed è stato emozionante
tutto questo per dirvi che la trama
della nostra vita la decidiamo noi siamo
noi a decidere
cosa farne della nostra vita e se l'ho
fatto io poi alla fine lo possono fare
tutti